This videos gonna be an interesting experiment to see if we can put out a quick meme
Basically, if we mess up one of these shots tomorrow, half the video is ruined
Drop it!
Before you watch this video make sure that you've gone to the Corridor channel and checked out the World's Bounciest Pogo Stick this
Whole video that you're about to watch on. This channel is spoilers for that video
So I recommend that you watch it first the links right below me in the description
It's the second link check it out and then click back and watch this video because it's gonna make a whole heck of a lot
more sense if you do
So Sam, and I have been thinking of this corridor video idea
It's kind of a continuation of the world's blankety-blank series the whole concept started as a joke between the two of us a pogo stick
kinda Just got us laughing Wren builds
The world's bouncies pogo stick shows it off to his friends
Boing he goes all the way up into the atmosphere and disappears when the camera pans down
We're in the same spot, but it's a hundred years later Wren's bones fall and smash
Unceremoniously on the ground I was there when the joke was originally murmured. I have a couple concerns if it's not done correctly
very quickly become one of those things that's funny to us and us only I mean
So the question becomes can they make an inside joke an outside joke?
The main thing is we know we need two shots
He goes up and he comes down we get a shot of Wren explaining his pogo stick and bouncing away into the sky
That's where we start defying expectations
We hold on the sky he disappears and as we slowly start panning back down a title comes up that says 100 years later
We show a spaceship then we pan down further and we see a cityscape and a future bag, man
What's a future bag man?
like you would be the scavenger
so
Final thing that happens right there the sixth thing that happens is the bones and the pogo stick come back down out of outer space
And that's already a lot. It doesn't need any more than that. So simple focused yet detailed execution
There's always this temptation
Especially on the creative side to want to add things because you want to show off how much?
You are capable of to the audience
but I think the key is really just
Boiling it down to what's necessary. If that doesn't happen. This this video is gonna fall completely apart
Now we're shooting tomorrow, and we only have a couple hours today to prep it
I've been kind of slaving away over this shot list here
umm i can
Actually show you I think it's complete in the second shot of this video and there's like this trash hobo
He's like a scrounger. We gotta find a costume that suits that, we got a lot to work with here
I want this trash hobo to have that guttural flair
I think the layers will be crucial here like layering different things on top of it. I love this
These are these rusty knee plates. These are great sewn leather. What type of skin? Is that? hobos game
I think we're kind of assuming that they use pants in the future. I
Need another layer at this point. i feel like a vest
yeah that one is not bad
You look like shrek
Get out of my swamp
The Shrek pocalypse. The Shrek pocalypse man, and yeah think its the  the accessories that change it. Yeah, that's better
How does it look?
I dont know. I think you need one of these
i think were good
this looks pretty solid
Also, I don't know what you wrapped your
left leg in but I like it
That is unexpected i love the asymmetry.  so
now that Sam's approved this costume we can make the Pogo stick prop and then I think we're good
I need some cool future lighting in here
Yeah, of course you pick Shrek green, of course dude,I  love Shrek, so here's our Pogo stick.
I think i can actually Pogo stick
Are you any good at Pogo stick? - im pretty good man. Oh
you just want to show off
Nor screwing around no more goofs. Yeah, we're making a Pogo stick what I'm doing to
This is kit-bashing it with random stuff that we have to make it look like it's a technological
Achievement. So this is gonna be the solar panel front half is silver in the back half because this is for the moon light, moon...
Lunar panels,there's a button you just connects to the capacitor upward thrust, you're up there
I'm not making this up as i go, we planned it
This is the new and improved, world's most bounciest Pogo stick. That will do donkey
Oh god.
i don't know how this became a Shrek thing.
Your whole life has been a stretch thing, you just didn't know it
ogers are like onions
Layering these distractions. i need another layer
LAYERS
In honor of today's sponsor crunchyroll, I'm gonna be commuting home on my new pogo stick. That's right
You guys don't know crunchyroll is the best place to catch anime outside of japan?
they've got all the new shows from all the new citizens that are coming out over there
and
The best part is it's made and created by people who actually love anime for people who love anime
It's not just some janky streaming service like this pogo stick is where it's created by some
Corporation to try to just make money on some content that they don't know what it's for
It's actually got all your favorite shows. My hero academia,
Attack on Titan, Ah
Dragon Ball super, and the best part is a lot of the shows come out only an hour after they air in Japan
another cool thing if you guys are already members and you already know about Crunchyroll just know that's some of the money you
Pay for your membership goes to anime artists in Japan
So they really actually support the community there, which is another awesome thing that I wanted
You guys to know about. now please if you guys already know About  Crunchyroll and you already watched shows on it
I'd leave a comment below about some of the shows that you watch because people who aren't into anime will want to know
Could definitely benefit by... by checking out those shows. So
Anyway, if you're interested
Go to crunchyroll.com
Slash corridor crew and you'll get 14-day free trial just by signing up
Guss what in here. Oh
What could it be
Its me. Can you
imagined actually just holding its skeleton like this by the spine
Fatality
Were chunking this off a bridge
If we mess up one of these shots tomorrow then half the video is not complete
Do you like those steaks dude? and we mess up one shot
HALF The video is ruined
Oh hello
Wren, since you died in this video
Does that mean this is the last of the worlds biggest videos?
No, Technically we all die at the end of the light saber video to
Also, I technically died the end of the slingshot video too I go to heaven. is Brenda Kenny of Corridor. he is.
Oh my god, they killed Kenny.
We're gonna sneak into the LA River looks like there's a whole village that sprung up around it
So we might have to like Bribe the city elder
Yo, so like what's the script? it's like Wren comes in with the announcement "Guys I built the world's bounciest Pogo stick!"
Action. oh guys, check it out. I've Done it this time -Stand back. I don't know how big the shock wave is gonna be
3.2.1 woa -Fatality
OH My god
Wren
that thing's called the ball busters
He is already a stunt man in movies -Yeah
AHH!
Wren! What the?
WREN!
I dont see him at all. He Disappeared, our baby boy
Alright cool, thanks
The Pogo stick, When it falls could either go like this and
Flip around and the skeleton will just kind of smack in or if it hits point first
it could bounce potentially and like we don't know where it's going to go
you tied bones to a Pogo stick?
It's like mafia shit
Next time you give us a bounce check
Were gonna make you bounce
There we go, you know, here's the pile. This is my swamp
Im about to drop a rock
Alright it hit right there I'm standing where it hit it's really close. Son That's Sketch
Whatever oh no, no, no, I'm doing it if it hits the camera. So be it because like here's the thing. Here's the thing
Here's the thing every single time. We think something's gonna hit the lens
or hit the camera most of the time it doesn't. we'll get a new lens if we really have to. it will suck
Obviously it'll be expensive but the shots we get by being risky are always worth it. Alright you guys ready?
Drop on your command. Ready?
In 3.2.1
Dropping
Perfect. That was totally in frame.
That was like almost perfect dude
His arms are attached- His arms are still there
Think you can still Pogo?
uhh no. She doesn't Pogo no mo?
She dont Pogo no mo.
How was it? Brutal. How was it?
It didn't bounce -woahhhhh
a little too eager there buddy. pretty much landed exactly how I thought it was gonna land just off to the side
But what I didn't anticipate was the skeletons it completely like dismembered itself on impact. It's like splash
That's a wrap.
That's a Wrap, Wren is so excited
Goodbye pogo stick
So we have two shots and we have to merge them and make them one shot with a hidden
Transition on top of that. We need to make an explosive pogo stick effect
And then we also need to make this lavish cityscape. This is a thicc tutorial
So we have an iPhone shot which is the first half of the video and that goes all the way up until
Wren explodes flies in outer space
So I have Wren here. I have him painted out then to just get our super cool giant explosion
I'm using a ton of action VFX elements here. I like these dust explosions a lot because they have a lot of power
There's a lot junk and debris and also a Video Copilot lens flare to cover it all up
So here's Wren's element here just by itself boom disappears. He's going to the head
so basically I take Wren's body and I turn it into a 3d layer and I just send that 3d layer up to the Moon
WREN!
But here's where the crucial part comes in the transition and this is kind of like the hardest part
I create a middle shot that matches with the iPhone in the beginning and matches with the red at the end and that way I
Don't need to get too specific with how these shots line up
Let me show you a little bit of how I did that I start by adding in a literal blue sky element that
Tracks up and down here. So if it pans up it pans up to my own sky, this is Sam's the sky
I basically have a hand animated 3d camera that generally matches the iPhone so that way when I pan up the
Sky and the clouds and Wren all generally line up and are at the right speed
So the 3d camera is perfectly smooth, but I'm using one of my favorite favorite plugins
It's the red giant camera shake now
This thing is a 2d plugin, what this is doing is making it so that it still feels like we're on the iPhone
So I can have the realistic camera shake
Slow down and then perfectly become still again
We pan down
we bring the camera shake down we'll bring some noise color grading, vignette up and
Best of all, we bring up the big shot to make the big shot. We have a pan down plate here. I
Did the actual pan right there while we were filming? I didn't leave that for After Effects sometime
when they to do that in post
It looks kind of fake and I use the cinema 42 the camera tracking tool and from there
I built out this cityscape using a lot of the kibish 3d packs and they are awesome. They're highly detailed
We rendered this out with cinema 4d and octane render, Nick boom spaceshi,  boom city, boom haze
Alright now, let's put back in some action VFX elements
Let's start with dust at camera eight dust front 10. I did MeMa's ashes sprinkling side 04
you need a little bit of grandfather's ashes at cam though. Yeah for you
All these cool dust elements are pretty sweet, but I figured hey, you know what?
I want to get this thing a little bit of extra spice. I've been inspired by a friend of ours
He posts a lot of really great stuff on his Instagram and YouTube channel. Ian. Hubert is an awesome visual effects artist
he's got this thing called lazy tutorials and one of them you can see a
Similar tutorial to what? I'm about to show you when the spaceship comes over
I don't want just a bunch of stock footage smoke and dust coming. I want to do something that is part of the scene
I made some rectangles put newsprint textures on them
Those were then run through a soft body simulation a cloth simulation technically, so they are actually matching the scene
They're matching the lighting. They're matching the lens to show the scale of this spaceship
Basically Wren's skeleton was filmed as a second plate as well
This is all we're doing we're just adding this
Element in and then I do a light mask on it as it collapses down to the ground. So that is the shot
It's a lot of stuff going on. This video. Honestly, it was a really really fun experiment to and building on a 3d city
It's used in a background
Definitely something I want to do a lot more of so that's what went into making the world's bouncies pogo stick if you Enjoyed this
Type of video, you know kind of the behind the scenes look at how we make productions here at corridor
Then you might want to check out the second playlist down in the description
It's chocked full of BTS videos and other educational filmmaking experiments that we've done who knows it might just learn something
Thanks for watching
Dude
Welcome to the pogo stick without moving your head challenge
oh i didn't know you were rolling. You were rolling?
Wait, keep that up. Keep that up.
You cant move your head
Subscribe to Corridor Crew!
Well Jake,uhhh... this is yours now